hello hi reject nation it's Greg Alba
here and it's John Humphrey over here so
we're gonna watch the clip today for
Justice League one or woman saves
hostages we've just seen six other movie
clips I saved this for last because I
figured it's probably just some cool
action scene and Wonder Woman saving the
day I want to do a patron the day
shout-out though for Natalie Duran
Natalie Duran cuz Natalie Duran
oh you're Linda we always got to do for
you girls
yes we always got to do our terrific
Irish accent we'll do a faster the
reaction for you my dog my doll oh my
dear my doll I do mob do my diddle
the journey of John Mike and Wonder
Woman progressed like to wonder I mean
rescue cocaine
[Music]
[Music]
dodged that bullet so is that the bomb
gonna destroy like everything I suppose
got super fast
[Music]
[Music]
a believer in light not blowing up and
throwing bombs really high instead of
letting them explode on the ground
maybe that's the ending scene and not
introduction a Wonder Woman his blows up
and then everybody's high five set up
for Wonder Woman - we got some new stuff
in that that was a new issue she can
move super fast I don't know if she was
flying or just jumping really hard but
they did it like she was flying she's
certainly lept she did the whole - a
great she did the super manly
yeah but her super speed that son in the
first Wonder Woman know I'm wondering
about that yeah yeah how does that work
where it comes when she first starts the
bullet I was like she just see it coming
in the gym the camera just slowed down
for that cool shot yeah she's moving
whoa she can move really fast now her
powers have developed her powers have
been enhanced well maybe she and the
flash got together or something like
that and there's like no no did she mean
I have a believer just try for about
another imagine radioactive for when you
know doomsday that first speech though
but daddy Bolton was making at the
beginning I can't wait till they get the
entire game of Thrones cast pretty soon
this week she was making though bringing
back the world is it like are they just
attacking corporate or something this
bomb supposed to be something else and
if it is this bomb and if it's not all
powerful white why here yeah yeah I like
these children seas may get some like
deep speech about destroying and bring
in his back into the dark ages and all
these things is this actually something
that's connected to Steppenwolf yeah
other things I thought from the trailers
like oh that's just them reintroducing
Wonder Woman saving the day you know but
hearing the the monologue he was giving
that sounds a little bit more like
there's something deeper going on
this hostage situation yeah the bomb is
really that strong how high was that
briefcase in the air where it didn't
really cause damage on ground expect
that bomb to be a little bit stronger
for some reason at least in yeah if he's
talking that game of like you know the
Dark Ages and leveling it all and yeah
like because it seems like it's a
suicide mission what these guys are all
yeah he doesn't seem to be concerned
about getting away from that yeah we
have a twenty seconds left and then
everyone's just chillin and they're
making sure everyone stays to die that
is getting me curious to know is this
some side plot set up for eerie
introducing Wonder Woman is this the
scene where oh [ __ ] okay yeah Wonder
Woman's back she's kicking ass or is
this actually gonna link to the bigger
picture of the movie's plot I am glad
that they're taking some time in these
clips to highlight the idea of you know
saving hostages yeah yeah doing
superhero things yeah well yeah cuz this
is something that especially Batman vs
Superman kind of lacked was like seeing
the impact on just real people and and
also in that previous clip where he's
telling the flash like go in save one
person and you'll know what to do after
that like I like that they're
emphasizing that this time and I think
all the clips one consistent thing I
feel about all the clips is the style
the vibe the rhythm all seems to have a
much more upbeat super heroic type of
vibe which I think they're succeeding in
in terms of it looks great the action
sequence images that we're getting look
pretty cool but in terms of just
dynamics of scenes I've just dialogue
it looks pretty solid to me right now
it's giving me morphine I already had
faith that this was gonna be an
entertaining thrill ride so that tells
me like the scenes will be boring either
just do like I don't know it's the
interaction won't be boring yeah I don't
think this is gonna wreck my day yeah I
think I'll probably have a fine time I
know right it's only two weeks why I got
tickets for Thursday night at Arclight
with John and Andrew and then I got
tickets for Sunday at IMAX at Universal
because I'm hoping to catch up on the
Punisher between all this but I do a
roof livestream keep a lookout but hey
not so neat Iran wants to give me a shot
out here because you are my Wonder Woman
send you some love from actually Natalie
was a Wonder Woman for halt know she was
going to be wonderful
and said she was a [ __ ] FBI cop 'we
know sexy
she didn't say [ __ ] I'm sorry sexy FBI
I just if you're dressed sexy I'm gonna
assume you're being [ __ ] okay that's
just the way I am I cap add values no no
I saw your costume you were lucky you
were appropriately dressed your mom
would have been okay you're an FBI agent
who would not have been written out for
me it's appropriate for an FBI agent you
are quite a Wonder Woman to us you are
you have such a kind soul you are so
friendly you're funny you got me into
arrow
we love you it's your this you're doing
but if we don't love you just now push
myself away instead of John I love you
battery's gonna die like a vintage
reject video subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
follow us on social media both of my
ears are ringing right now hope that
urgent care visit will take care of this